all right guys bang-bang lunch money
time while while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us trying to get her
lunch money right I'm here with the
beautiful intelligent plain Tamara Nova
and special guest mr. mee boho Kalina
here say hello every day
[Laughter]
exactly don't forget lunch money's now
sponsored by block by block Fry's got
three products you can buy and sell
crypto you can deposit crypto and take
out a u.s. dollar loan or you can
deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent a py in an
interest-bearing account I'm an investor
and a user go check them out at bought
by comm slash lunch money
polina what's the first topic say for
the first topic so this headline is
misleading it says nearly half the u.s.
population is without a jobs not which
my dad was like half the u.s. population
it's half the working US population is
without a job at plunge to fifty two
point eight percent and in May
meaning that forty seven point two
percent of Americans are jobless it's
crazy
absolutely insane get people back to
work right even of course I agree take
measures but intelligently not like
everybody stay home that's it's just
look the virus is real people gotta stay
safe but I will say this you ready this
is what really frustrates me I went to a
subway yesterday for lunch and when we
walked in the subway there was everyone
in there had a mask on including myself
and my brothers but there was two old
guys in their 70s who had no masks on
hey Eddie
we have these on for you if I hit
rotavirus I'm not gonna die right if you
get it you're gonna die put your damn
mask on if I gotta wear one you gotta
wear one crazy yeah so look we gotta get
people back to work awesome so Cirque du
Soleil files for bankruptcy fun fact
Anthony once in Las Vegas danced with a
clown on the Cirque de Soleil stage one
of my moves
he's always dancing just wanna have a
good time
look I think circus Olay like not
surprising that you take a in person
show that is reliant on revenue coming
from people going to a show they don't
have many other revenue streams of
course they're gonna suffer and two
three months all of a sudden there's a
lot of pressure and so bankruptcy again
as we've learned has not does not mean
that circus Olay is gonna go away just
means they're gonna restructure the
capital stack and the equity owners will
probably get wiped out maybe even some
debt owners and and they'll get back to
work Cirque du Soleil is one of those
interesting things where it's not the
same watching it virtually you have to
go in person you've got it's an
experience you go you've been you've
been to a circus dalle yes yes yeah see
you gotta go person experience yeah
police right you have to go there
because watching by the way speaking of
virtual only events my dad plays one
minute chess he says that you can go on
the site and watch people live play
chess hold on a second don't disrespect
my dick isn't just play chess he's one
of the best people in the world I'm not
good okay
grandmasters with you oh you know these
direct it's a rating the chess player
basically it's like a ranking like like
you can watch which is crazy watch how
they play like but it's not the same as
in person we're almost done
Lululemon is acquiring the in-home
fitness company mirror for five hundred
million dollars
making its first acquisition with a bed
that more people are gonna be exercising
from home so we remind us what mirrors
mirrors that company here is they it's a
thing that stands on the floor and when
it's turned off it's a full-length
mirror and then when they turn it on it
basically is like an interactive at home
gym so there's a person where avatar
that pops up and they tell you the
exercises to do so they say you know hey
do this do that whatever and it's kind
of like having a virtual trainer right
there in front of you telling you what
to do you can do everything from
one-on-one coaching to group exercises
or group classes all that and I think it
retails you can buy it's like fourteen
fifteen hundred bucks and then you pay I
think it's like thirty or fifty dollars
a month something like a subscription
service or alternatively you could turn
on YouTube and do an exercise on there
yeah for sure but I think part of its
like the accountability the tracking
like all that kind of stuff and then
look it's also a thing where mirror this
year the CEO of Lululemon says gonna do
a hundred million dollars in revenue so
it's pretty big business and they're
gonna break even early next year
but ultimately just comes down to
historically the fitness companies they
create their apparel brands right so
like there's a CrossFit gym and they
create some t-shirts or something very
rarely do you see
this happened in Reverse we're an
apparel company buys the at-home fitness
or the the physical location you know
what's funny everybody was making fun of
mirror and saying nobody's gonna do this
and pay 1495 and then $39 per month to
do this but now in coronavirus
everyone's homes with you are actually
purchasing it and it's they they did
really well I mean the investors in your
raised so they invested seventy two
million dollars and it got bought for
five hundred million that's a pretty big
return yeah I mean it is likely that
they only made depending on where you're
on the capital stack but I bet you the
average return for an investor so they
got a 1x liquidity preference so that
leaves about you know called four
hundred and twenty five million dollars
of that which employees and the founders
probably owned a material part so like I
bet you most investors made somewhere
and the like you know three to five X
range was still pretty good return
obviously the early investors made a
killing right first round I think was
one of the investors but the other thing
that's really interesting is Lululemon
actually was an investor in mirror
they'd invested a million bucks
yeah Evo is a workout warrior
he like go for a run and you but how far
is your money like twelve miles nobody
or bikes all right what's next okay so
you know tick-tock
India is banning tick tock and several
other well-known Chinese apps saying
they pose a threat to sovereignty and
integrity
so basically India doesn't like China
right now it how can you ban tick tock
it's gonna happen in the US you think so
yep the US military the US military RT
banned tick tock you can't if you're a
soldier you can't use tick tock yep
India obviously just did they also
banned WeChat and a bunch of other ones
I don't think that they'll go that far
in the US but I definitely think that at
some point they are going to ban tick
tock and there's a
a threat us on Twitter recently where
somebody reverse engineered the tic-tock
software and they saw all the things
that they're taking while the software's
on your phone like all the data it's
really bad it's probably one of the most
invasive applications that I've seen and
so ultimately just comes down to like
we're gonna see the nationalization of
all these apps right people are
literally gonna say if you're in the
United States we don't want you using
any Chinese application so here's the US
what do you mean I mean well there's a
couple of things so one is obviously the
app stores like Apple could just kick it
out of the App Store but they would have
to get some sort of pressure to do that
or they'd have to make the decision by
themselves not the government do it
Google obviously could do the same thing
and then on top of that the US
government I guess technically could
like ban you from using the software
right they could say like hey if you use
tik-tok softwares you know it's spy
software or something and so they just
do it that way they banned the almost
the ownership of the software the usage
of the software
fun fact my little sister Catherine and
I made a tik tok dance once you saw it
it was great it was
I think Evo and I are in the same boat
on this one it was not entertaining I
feel bad I feel like Evo's in a hostage
video right now he's there with all with
his daughters and his wife like you know
he needs another guy there you got him
held hostage Jeff Bezos just sold 1.8
billion in Amazon stock to fund his
space venture and he's still still the
richest man in the world even though he
sold 1.8 billion yeah that's like 20
bucks for Jeff Bezos that's crazy
put it this way he went through the
divorce gave away 30 billion dollars to
his ex-wife and still the richest man in
the world because he erupts small
businesses like mine Evo Evo selling
Amazon ego what do we think about Amazon
yeah I think it should be gone I think
we have to go in the revolution how much
what percentage do they take of sales
it depends what kind of ABA needs to be
sent to Amazon our products and they
sell it to the customers okay okay the
second thing the second option is we
show directly again through Amazon
platform but we send it directly to the
customer so in the first case in the
first case FDA so abuse then if you send
your product to Amazon's warehouse and
then they ship it from there
they take 30% but if BOM okay but if you
send it directly to the customer how
much do they take it's more take a $6 so
about so so a little less than 20% yeah
okay well Jeff Bezos has got billions of
dollars because he's been doing that for
years that's correct so what do you
think Jeff business is gonna do with the
space venture is he like it now inspired
by Elon Musk
they're competing compress my Elon Musk
as well I must keep tweet madam tell him
he's a copycat next okay last one Kim
kardashian-west is selling a stake in
her beauty brand she also has a beauty
brand like Kylie Jenner for 200 million
dollars in a deal that values the
business at 1 billion she's selling it
also to cody co t why
that did they they're the one who did
Kylie Jenner right listen Oh get a 20%
stake so k'kaw is valued at 1 billion
that's Kim Kardashian's brand and Kylie
Jenner's is valued at 1.2 billion when
they did it she owned a hundred percent
I believe so they bought 20% of it so
yeah yeah I mean look that that means
that both the sisters are billionaires I
don't care what Forbes says Forbes
doesn't how to do math basically Kylie
Jenner's not a billionaire my dad thinks
that they became famous for nothing
listen no businesses afterwards but it
still doesn't mean that they didn't
become famous for nothing like let's
just call what it is Kim Kardashian
became famous for a sex tape listen to
this so Kody's trans Kody owns covergirl
Max Factor Sally Hansen nail polish it
cannot they cannot compete with k'kaw
beauty's reach Max Factor for example
has 585 thousand Instagram followers
k'kaw beauty has 4.4 million so if you
have the distribution you can sell
anything
yeah everyone go check out Atlanta
Chemical and go buy Evo tell us whether
tell us what people use the paint
pigment for a lot of things always a
spectrum of the magician yeah we have
magician who make tricks but we don't
know actually is not even right what
everyone knows I Evo has a business that
basically they sell paint pigment which
you don't we basically means
color-changing products like paintings
public baths when it gets exposed to
heat we have another product you exposed
to sunlight which is contains UV
component and exactly the UV changes the
cour not temperature which is beautiful
so people have basically take
and they've done everything from cool
art like there's one guy who basically
like did a piece of art and then he lit
it on fire and it changed colors to
people created what is it like slime
right so the could put their hand in the
slime and it would change colors because
they heat of your handsome face masks
when you really change the color
so basically Evo sends it you'd be the
ingredients then you can build all these
cool things was funny because I went
viral and tik-tok just some girl
painted the face mess it was like a
Harry Potter mask and she breathed and
it changed the cool I don't crazy we're
so so Jeff Bezos doesn't get rich where
can people go by Atlantic chemical calm
[Laughter]
just to sell things on the internet man
just trying to sell things on the
Internet do you have any parting words
before I get to my joke no joke okay
it's not gonna be funny don't worry why
did the coach go to the bank you can get
this annoyed why did the coach go to the
bank
yeah it's true that's where the money is
no to get his quarterback to funny I'm
too funny that's it for today guys thank
you for watching lunch money be nice to
your dad's alright guys that's it for
lunch money well while she's trying to
get rich the rest of us she's trying to
get a lunch money right we'll talk to
you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by black 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that
and click on I'm an investor a user and
a huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
Blackfyre than you are of me block wise
my second favorite thing in the world
behind Polina
they've got three products they can give
you a u.s. dollar loan you can earn up
to eight point six percent interest on
an interest-bearing account or you can
buy and sell cryptocurrencies on there
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy playing in
the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow
and be kind to your friends